- Des signatures, aussi appelée.
Sur des appartements,
des commerces, ou des
infrastructures publiques,rs det
fréquemment vandalisés
- Omar Deharbi en sait quelq
chose, c'est lui qui gère
l'édifice.
- Les graffiteurs reviendront
d'ici deux semaines selon lui.
JOHN KERSTE, employé
chez Solueueueueueueueueueueueue
je viens ici, je pense que
les gens qui viennent ici aiment
- À Montréal, le service
r chaquer chaquer chaquer chaque
arrondissement.
En une quarantaine de minutes,
le mur ele mur ele mur ele mur .
Vandalisme pour certain,
de l'art pour d'autres.
MATTHEW CADOCH, artiste
- Je pense que pour apprécier
les "tags", tu dois être
une persfaire des graffitis illt
une manière pour des jeunes,
issus de milieux plus
difficiles, d'exprimer
leur créativité sa
Ce qui fait un "tag" beau,
c'est les histoires en arrière."
d'un artiste de Los Angeles qui
était là pendant 2 semaines
en 2001 et qu'il a fait un
encore là, et c'eende
qui a peinturé partout dans
le monde. Moi, je sais, mais
pour la personne ordinaire,
c'est juste un a
contribué au développement
de nombreux artistes.
- J'ai des amis dans
mon collectif qui font
les incroyables dans
cette ville que tout le monde
apprécie. La ville n'a aucune
idée que cette même personne a
fait ce "tag" que dans tes yeux
c'est juste un autre "tag".
- Au déb
les signalements pour
des graffitis ont augmentés.
particulièrement dans
les quarre etre etre etre etre t
président de Solutions Graffiti
lent être
visibles, c'est pas pour rien
qu'ils vont au centre-ville,
et qu'ils mettent une grosse
affaire au 10e étage.
C'est pas pour rien qu'ils vont
à l'échangeur Tursouvent.
- L'échangeur Turcot est
nettoyé deux fois par année.e gé
enlevés.
LOUIS-ANDRÉ BERTRAND,
porte-pais
par années. On les retire.
Les équipes vont les nettoyer.
njeux avec
la population, c'est que
les gens ne se rendent pas
compte qu'on a faitdeux semaines
plus tard, les graffiteurs vont
revenir.- Le nettoyage peut pree
une demi-journée pour un secteur
donné. Si le graffiti est
sur la structure, ça nécessietut
avoir lieu que la fin
de semaine, avec d
Ça demande vraiment d'aller
chercher plusieurs personnes.ri0
dollars pour nettoyer
les graffitis.dollarsdollarsdols
Dans le Plateau, le budget
annuel pour 2022 p
dollars, un montant trois fois
plus élevé qu'en 2019.
MAXIME G- On aura jamais le desr
les graffitis parce que c'est
un phéno va toujou va toujou vas
exister, mais on arrive a avoir
un certain contrôle.
- L'opposition officiellevoudrae
une manière uniforme pour
la gestion des graffitis.
AREF SALEM, chef de l'opposilem,
chaque arrondissement, il fait
comme il veut. Une ville qui se
respecte doit au moins donne
le guide, une façon de faire
à ses arrondissements et sumett.
- Pour Matthew Cadoch, réprimer
et effac
la solution.
- C'est beaucoup plus complexe
que ça. s
de ces histoires-là, ça ne va
pas réparer les situations.
On a besoin d'organismes
intégrésles ressources qu'ils ot
besoin.
- Pour certains, l'argent pour
nettoyer les graffitis devraêtr.
Pour d'autres, la ville tarde à
nettoyer les graffMais il est de
impossible, d'encadrer l'art
urbain. C'est ce qui en fait
son essence.
Ici Marie-Isabelle Rochon,
Radio-Canada, Mon